well a Las Vegas food truck parked
behind a chicken wing restaurant is
gaining some serious traction online so
it's actually off of us of a Centennial
Parkway and 5th Street in North Las
Vegas thanks to social media it's soon
getting even bigger reporter Ryan
Matthey gives us a taste now you're
cooking Frankie
Chef Shawn's secret ingredient love that
is
boy have I been waiting to try taste
buds Creole kitchen from a small town in
Illinois to behind a Buffalo Wild Wings
in North Las Vegas Marshawn Nelson and
his wife Latricia had a dream when we
came out here we started from the ground
up like just putting plates in people's
face like taste this taste buds Creole
kitchen was born a small family food
truck serving up jerk chicken beef
greens alfredo pasta but the star of the
show I'm convinced I just had the best
Mac and Cheese of my life their mac and
cheese stopping Scrolls Online their
Instagram over 30 000 followers Tick
Tock videos with millions of likes and
views we got people that just fly in and
they're like hey I saw you from Detroit
I saw you on Tick Tock I'm from Arkansas
I saw you on Instagram thank you have a
good one so popular wait times reaching
over an hour for the freshly made food
I'm all about it like for many who dried
it for the first time Friday I just
actually moved here from Indiana so I'm
trying to find places that look like
look and feel like home and this gave me
that by the best mac and cheese in the
world that's what some people are
calling this dish and when you pair it
with the rest of the menu and that large
audience online the small dream scene
here soon turning into a big reality
that was always our goal was to get into
a brick and mortar but the demand has us
getting in there a little bit faster
than we expected
in North Las Vegas Ryan Matthey 8 News
Now